i wanna i wanna i wanna throw it to our
good friend lebron james let's let's
call out these evil people
lebron james mocks kyle rittenhouse's
courtroom breakdown what tears knock it
off i'll be quick with this one
here's his tweet usa today said cal
right now broke down in tears at his
murder trial while on the witness stand
as he described the events of august
25th 2020 in kenosha lebron james says
what tears followed by five question
marks i didn't see one man knock it off
that boy ate some lemon heads before
walking into court here's a getty
photograph of a tear on kyle
rittenhouse's face
i watched it happen it took me two
seconds to google search a high
resolution image from the daily beast
left in publication by the way where you
can literally see the tear coming out of
kyle rittenhouse's eye he was having a
panic attack and he was crying
and it was real
and people like lebron james don't care
about truth he didn't do a simple google
search he didn't take five seconds he
doesn't care all the listen
it has been a decade the culture war has
been
mob mentality i watched it happen to
luke when we were in hamburg germany
luke was walking down the street and a
random person screamed nazi schweinhund
and random people who've never seen luke
in their life got up and ran up started
punching him in the head that is what we
are dealing with i was like i'm polish
you son of a gun
this is not you're german i'm polish my
family literally died through your
freaking people killing my people i had
in the in the video
in the video that's crazy
there are people sitting on a curb yeah
and then all of a sudden someone yells
nazi schweinhund and points at luke and
they get up and start punching luke
they're just looking for a phone they
don't know who he is they don't know
what he represents they don't know what
he's doing they don't care and that's
what lebron james is that's what the
rioters are and that's what gage
grosskreutz was he was a guy who said
don't know don't care i'm going to
attack this person well there was a
major mainstream journalist i'm not
going to deflect too much here but there
was a major mainstream journalist in
germany that
sent out my picture to everyone saying
he's definitely someone you got to
target an attack and people just blindly
followed it without even understanding
my background my history my lineage but
that's another story
tim i disagree with you
let me say to to go back to the earlier
reference the journalist who posted
luke's photo is like the necromancer
necromancers raised the dead and raised
the zombies and then the zombies
attacked luke people who had no idea
they're mindless hordes
they should attack him because someone
told them to now i disagree with you
with your take on lebron i think his his
judgment is great especially when it
came to jesse smolette he knew that the
attack on him was was authentic he's a
great uh character judge of character
judge of character china and uh he loves
china and and his i mean his take on the
jesse smilet thing is the complete
opposite of what he's doing here he has
50.3 million followers tweeting that
kind of unethical uh
you know just un what's the word that
i'm looking for unhinged and not just
unhinged but but just uncaring kind of
words towards this entire situation
him being a thought leader him being a
major leader uh for a lot of culture uh
really is pushing this to the to the
it's not as as bad as joy reid but but
it's pushing it to that kind of scenario
pushing it towards that situation and
for for someone to mock someone when
they're going through clear signs of
ptsd um it's it's it's it's very
untasteful and it leads to this kind of
immoral kind of behavior that only
escalates things even further from here
i from lebron's hometown i feel like in
another universe we're we're pretty good
friends but he
has a lot of compassion but not a lot of
intellect
love you man but
he's he's outside he's a bad guy he's
just too powerful for a normal guy
i i think you can't be 18 and be told
you're the chosen one and and get that
tattoo on your back and be too
it's the same as the kardashians it's
the same as as a lot of our elected
officials i think we have too much of a
worship culture and these people do
begin to believe that they are that much
smarter that much look barack obama
thinks he's the smartest person in the
world because people have told him that
you listen to one of his policies and
they're atrocious you see it in evidence
joe biden thinks he's one of the
smartest people in the world because
he's been told that i've been in the
senate for 60 some years and lebron is
probably the same way it's amazing
celebrities you know bruce springsteen
thinks he has insights what did what
does bill gates know about science the
guy is a coder no he's not and yet he's
a whole long name he's sorry he's a tech
no he's a businessman he's a businessman
bought programs and sold them there you
go i'm sure he understands something you
probably understand some but now he's
talking about agriculture policy and
it's in healthcare policy it's like dude
shut up you don't know everything i know
you're rich but shut up you don't know
everything but these people do begin to
think they know everything that's
lebron's problem i'll throw this to the
left there is an honest and good
critique
in
just because someone knows how to make
money does not mean they should wield
power over policy in other positions
george soros is single-handedly
contributing to the downfall in this
country when he dumps money into various
foundations that get district attorneys
elected who stop prosecuting crime and
then crime escalates just because he
knows how to do hedge fund whatever and
bet on stocks doesn't mean he knows how
to run policy and so what ends up
happening in our system for better or
for worse
is that people make tons of money from
one thing they might be good at and then
use that money to influence things they
know nothing about
now i don't know what the solution is
because i don't think communism is a
better outcome just randomly giving
power to people but i certainly think
there's a problem of bill gates buying
the dos operating system from someone
for 50 grand then licensing it to ibm at
a dollar per computer which makes him
rich and now all of a sudden he's a
vaccine expert buying farmland
yeah bill gates can come out and make a
statement and the media and and big tech
will allow whatever he says
who is he to make medical judgments
he's not a doctor thomas soul calls this
kind of person who's good at one thing
the benighted because these are people
who can make these choices and who
suffer zero consequences if this doesn't
pan out but i wanted to ask you guys do
you think that lebron james is like the
necromancer or is he like one of the
zombies zombie i feel like he's
somewhere in between because he has so
many followers he's like uh it's like
when uh a one uh a one uh uh
a giant is is no no a better yet here's
a better way to put it zombie giant lord
maybe maybe but i think a better way to
put it is when the khaleesi's dragon
fell down beyond the wall and then the
white walker rose the dragon from the
dead and became a lich dragon like very
powerful but still a zombie yeah people
i think can phase between zombie lord
and zombie yes you can reason with the
zombie lord you can't reason with the
zombies so if you catch henry kissinger
on the street and you directly ask him a
question he's gonna have a hard time
lying because he's not in that state of
dissonance all the time he knows this
yeah so that's why a lot of your work is
fascinating because you've found these
people in their weak point spots yeah
and get them to say things that you're
like how no zombie would the zombies are
already blockaded from that from that
truth remember donald rumsfeld yeah well
we ran into the lakers everything i have
no idea what you're talking about yeah
yeah no no no when he gave a press
conference on that exact same issue and
we just asked him another question about
that uh but but yeah a lot of these
people you know when when they're just
zombies they're just you know there's
really no getting through them uh
there's really no kind of hope for them
for a lot of people that's the kind of
larger ideas when we're when we're
talking about zombies i don't think
that's the case here i think some people
act like zombies but i think there's
also a chance for a lot of people to
wake up because at some points i think
all of us were zombies i think all of us
were in the dated at some point to be
completely blind to another reality npcs
and totally unaware and totally by you
know played by the fiddle by the
mainstream media that's telling us
we can fall back into it that's the
danger people can slip back into
zombification if you're not vigilant but
not everybody i mean luke you have a
long history of constantly challenging
government officials and i mean you you
were a teenager yelling at you know
these these government actors and stuff
like that there are a lot of people who
have always questioned and challenged
but i do think it's fair to say there
are a lot of people who are waking up to
this there uh anna kasparian yeah my
nothing but risk nothing i will say
nothing but respect in this moment that
she said i was wrong she looked at the
evidence
she was in a bubble she's an angel now
she saw the truth the white fire of
purity burned her zombie skin away
so many characters
i'm not going to say that but but i i i
think again i'm still stuck on your on
your t-shirt i mean you look at you look
at the course of of not not even all of
history just the last 150 years i mean
chairman mao watched a hundred million
people die because he had this ideology
that he had to implement and i'm sure
people were like but my whole family my
whole village they're all dead and he
was like yeah but you know like
it's
it's sad i think this west virginia i
forget his name
i think they they see the the the
um um west virginia the the kenosha
riots i see they think all this is kind
of necessary like these are these it's
unfortunate it's the same as the people
who said we can't let donald trump win
so we have to say hydroxychloroquine is
deadly because if you die from your lung
fluid sorry but we have a greater agenda
human beings
have a problem
where they assume everyone thinks the
way they think
and so one of the problems you'll see on
the right
is that people on the right have
consistently said things like
why would anyone want injustice in this
trial like they genuinely don't
understand why leftists are doing what
they do i saw a really important tweet
though from a progressive leftist
journalist who said
something to the effect of kyle
rittenhouse and his supporters stand in
the way of racial transformative justice
and blah blah blah blah blah the point
was this is where i was like i'm i
understand their world view
when
black lives matter rioters even child
abusers like rosenbaum
burn down buildings and beat people to
death like well let's just not say in
this particular ends of the rosenbaum
not to death but in kenosha bashed a
seven-year-old man over the back of the
rock leaving him bleeding on the ground
burning down his building
they view that as the path towards
racial justice
we
don't we think but but they're reckless
and they're criminals they see it as we
got to burn down these buildings and
you're standing in our way because
you're evil
what we
independents libertarians classical
liberals conservatives need to
understand is they don't view riots and
murder as injustice they view that as
the necessary path towards racial equity
we view that as i don't understand why
they would cause harm this way
freedom tunes has a very great cartoon
they just put out sheamus big fan and
good friend of the show
where it's two people talking to a
leftist and he says family friendly show
by the way the man who abused children
in this instance you know why are you
defending him and the leftist is like
i'm you know
oh no why would you that poor man
and they're like why would you support
someone who does this
and then the joke is
sheamus in the cartoon says this guy
kind of looks like voldemort and then
the leftist goes and then thinks of cow
right now says harry potter whatever
that joke while i agree is funny doesn't
understand in my opinion
how the left perceives rosenbaum and the
kenosha riots they're not supporting um
a a child abuser they're supporting
burning down buildings and destroying
american institutions as necessary for
justice they think it is it is lawful
good that's what they genuinely believe
lawful good to burn down and destroy
things
because they live in a different moral
framework with the paladin man lawful
good obsession can lead you astray if
you think something's evil when it's not
you go full
bore into destroying it yep that is a
very dangerous way to live these are
this is 100 i think because they are
ideologues their their overarching idea
is over everything and this is where the
saying you have to break a few eggs to
make an omelette comes from in my
understanding this is something where
you have to sacrifice a few children a
few people whose lungs fill up with
fluid doesn't really matter because
you're getting your end goal
that's all they're going for thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to watch
live you can check out this channel
monday through friday at 8pm and don't
forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you